[موسيقى]
الفرق ما بين دراسه الباحث العربي او
دراسه المستشرق الذي اتى الى المنطقه
العربيه لاجراء دراسه هو الاهداف الاختلاف
في الاهداف فالباحث العربي يتناول
دراسه هذه المجتمعات للوصول الى حقائق
تاريخيه تفيد في توثيق تاريخه بينما
المستشرق كان هدفه هدف سياسي لوجستي
بامتياز واحيانا استخبارات واحيانا
استخبارات عرفت كيف
[موسيقى]
العلم القادر من وجهه نظري على دراسه هذه
الظواهر في التغير وفي التطور الحضاري
السعودي هو علم الانتروبولوجيا السعوديه
كونه يمتاز بسمتين السمه الاولى هو يستطيع
ان يدرس المجتمع السعودي في مراحله الاولى
ومرحلته الان او المرحله الراهنه ويجري
دراسه مقارنه ما بين الماضي والحاضر اضافه
الى ان يستعين بمنهج الانتروبولوجيا
التطبيقيه لتطبيق النتائج العلميه التي
توصلت اليها الانتروبولوجيا السعوديه في
دراسه المجتمع السعودي خلال فترات زمنيه
محدده واماكن جغرافيه محدده مع مقارنتها
بمنجزات الحاضر
بهدف بناء نظريه علميه لبناء مستقبل زاهر
فيما يتعلق بالتطور التنموي السعودي
[موسيقى]